[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the war in ukraine has made us
accustomed to hearing news about
sanctions and blockades of financial
assets yachts airplanes real estate and
endless wealth of all kinds in the hands
of russian oligarchs now what exactly do
we mean by an oligarch are they the real
masters of russia the shadow rulers how
far does their power extend who are they
i am sure that when many of you hear the
term russian oligarchs you think of
millionaires with a lot of power and yes
simplifying things we could say that
they are something like that however the
same definition could apply for example
to many american billionaires without
digging too deep there is the case of
donald trump a multi-millionaire who
came to occupy the most important
position of power in the united states
of america and perhaps in the world but
clearly trump is not an oligarch and it
would be a mistake to label him as such
and so visualpolitik fans in this video
we're gonna tell you how the russian
shadow political system works who the
real masters of russia are and how the
relationship between the kremlin and the
oligarchs work listen up
[Music]
ever since vladimir putin unleashed his
storm of fire destruction and
annihilation on ukraine we've been
talking a lot about oligarchs but what
exactly is an oligarch i think this is
the first question we need to answer
well russian oligarchs are extremely
wealthy businessmen whose fortunes and
business depend essentially on how close
they are to the kremlin
[Music]
in this way the russian oligarch have
become something like the praetorian
guard of political power an extension of
the political arms of the kremlin in the
economic field because the russian
economy is something like a closed and
centralized economy where civil servants
and bureaucrats have been replaced by
rentia businessmen who make their way
through influence coercion and bribes in
today's russia neither a capitalist nor
a socialist model operates putin's
russia is something like the living
representation of a modern clique
mercantilism or crony capitalism a model
where large companies receive all kinds
of privileges from the political power
in exchange for supporting that power
and following its guidelines therefore
in this country the relationship between
private wealth and public power is very
close the oligarchs direct and control
strategic sectors for moscow's interests
such as for example energy or defence
[Applause]
now how does this all come about in
practice is this something new from
vladimir putin's russia well the truth
is that it is not
in fact we could say that we are already
in at least the second generation of
russian oligarchs because the first
generation emerged from the chaotic
privatization process that the country
underwent during the 1990s when the
russian state sold off many of the large
public enterprises of the soviet era at
bargain prices it was a process riddled
with corruption that was based on stock
loan schemes a system that used the
shares of large public natural resource
companies as a kind of collateral for
loans to the federal government and
since the federal government did not
repay those loans in a suspiciously
intentional manner then the creditors
who were tycoons and characters close to
power auctioned those shares to recover
their loans auctions that of course were
opaque and rigged where they presented
themselves as the only buyers
and this is how the oligarchs were born
and how they took control of the
country's large companies in this way
the civil servants and public
bureaucrats were replaced by these new
businessmen from socialism we went to
clique mercantilism this whole process
took place during the yeltsin era but in
reality the putin era has not been so
different if anything it's been an
evolution of this system
[Music]
boris yeltsin and vladimir putin were
antagonistic characters who despite
their political ties did not get along
well with each other and of course each
of them had their own groups of
influence which in practice were
adversaries so with putin came the
second generation of oligarchs his
entourage made its way through generous
government contracts concessions and
permits to exploit the country's riches
or supposedly develop national industry
in this way they gradually occupied the
highest rungs of the russian economic
structure
it may surprise you but russia's clinque
mercantilism doesn't work much
differently from organized crime groups
in fact the russian president is a
specialist in getting rid of anyone who
makes him uncomfortable for example by
leading anti-corruption campaigns
take the case of mikhail koldikovsky an
oligarch very close to yeltsin and one
of russia's greatest fortunes who was
imprisoned in 2003 on corruption charges
kodakovsky was the owner of the russian
oil company yukos which was expropriated
by the russian government
police in russia seized oil tycoon
russia's richest man the oil baron
mikhail b cordovsky was seized at
gunpoint on saturday by government
security agents and jailed on charges of
fraud and tax evasion yes all these
accusations may have been true but they
were certainly not exceptional
corruption is a necessary part of the
prevailing political model in the
country this 2003 operation against
russia's largest fortune was putin's
first warning shot to the oligarchs the
message went something like watch out
watch out watch out if you still want to
go out on your own you will suffer the
consequences you are where you are
thanks to the political power so if you
are not completely loyal you will pay
dearly
[Music]
in other words we're not talking here
about businessmen competing with each
other and taking risks not at all the
russian mercantilist model replaces
competition with favored deals influence
peddling bribery and corruption of all
kinds in exchange for their fortunes
that oligarchs undertake to maintain
stability loyalty to political power and
try to run their companies as well as
possible at least better than the
results achieved when the companies were
public but now that we know what exactly
an oligarch is and why they are much
talked about the question is who exactly
are the owners of russia what changes
did vladimir putin bring about how far
does the russian president's influence
over the country's big business extend
well let's take a look
[Music]
russian shareholders
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the russian oligarchic model as we have
told you has basically gone through two
stages that of yeltsin and that of putin
the first was characterized by the
enormous political power that some of
the oligarchs garnered on some occasions
they even dictated to the government the
direction of its policies or became
members of the cabinet of the government
however in the second stage this
situation changed radically putin
established a very different
relationship with an iron fist the
oligarchs would no longer interfere or
put conditions on the government
russia's power is in the kremlin not in
the headquarters of these companies
[Music]
in this way putin pushed for rules and
laws so that the big oligarchs of
strategic industries such as energy
mining or the media would sell part of
their shares to the state or to entities
controlled by it the idea was to further
tighten the ties between the kremlin and
large russian corporations and this is
how the so-called state corporations
were born which putin legally shielded
with preferential treatment and
privileges of all kinds it is estimated
that these corporations now control 55
of the russian economy it is a variant
of state capitalism that has given putin
unprecedented control over the most
important productive sectors of the
country and also over their owners
that is to say unlike in the yeltsin era
russian oligarchs in practice are no
longer limited to being the owners of
large industrial conglomerates but are
above all responsible for managing these
groups on behalf of the kremlin in this
way the bribes and rents extracted from
these large companies reach all the
levers of power in the country
[Music]
that is the great change that has taken
place and it is what has given vladimir
putin unprecedented power and this is
also what explains that despite all the
international sanctions russia is
suffering after the invasion of ukraine
the oligarchs have barely spoken out
because now they depend on putin more
than putin depends on them of course
this system leads to very poor levels of
productivity innovation and
competitiveness but it does guarantee
enormous stability for all parties
except of course for the vast majority
of russians but having said that there
is an obvious question that arises who
exactly are the country's main oligarchs
[Music]
the friends of the kremlin
[Music]
[Applause]
currently in russia we can find three
types of oligarchs firstly there are
putin's friends who are connected on a
personal level with the president his
inner circle we are talking for example
about former friends from saint
petersburg where the russian president
grew up or former colleagues from the
kgb then there are the leaders of the
security services fsb police and
military who are known as the silo vicky
and finally we have the outsiders well
with regard to this last group these are
people who literally owe putin
everything people who have managed to
multiply their wealth to unimaginable
levels since putin came to power they
are the faithful among the faithful
take the case of yuri kovalchuk known as
putin's personal banker and who has a
master fortune of 1.7 billion he is
currently the main shareholder of rossia
bank one of the largest banks in the
country but if this sounds like a lot of
money check out leonid mikkelsen another
personal friend of the russian
government mikkelsen has a fortune
estimated at 18.1
billion and is currently listed at
number 66 among the richest people in
the world according to forbes mikkelsen
is the founder and director of nova tech
a natural gas company which is currently
sanctioned by the west precisely because
of its ties to the kremlin
then another personal friend of the
president gennady timchenko who has
managed to annas a fortune of 15.7
billion dollars through the vulgar group
his investment company through which he
invests in corporations controlled by
other oligarchs
[Music]
then in the silowiki camp of the
oligarchs who came from the security
services and so on we have the example
of igor sechin who is now president of
the russian oil company rosneft but who
in the 1980s was a soviet spy in
mozambique although officially his
activity was listed as a mere translator
i hope i don't get novochox poisoning
from talking about all these oligarchs
putin understood early on that having
full control of the security services
and gaining the absolute loyalty of
their leaders was a key step in
consolidating his power so he enriched
them beyond measure and then finally in
the outsider group we have a number of
men who managed to save themselves from
putin's purge of oligarchs following the
yeltsin era
one of them is vladimir potanin who
benefited from yeltsin's loan for share
scheme to a massive fortune that totals
16.5 billion today putanen owns 30 of
norelisk nickel a major mining company
as well as stakes in insurance media oil
and a long list of other companies
as you can see in russia fortunes are
not built by entrepreneurial spirit but
above all by contact with the kremlin
and take note because we are not talking
about small change the great russian
billionaires accumulate wealth valued
between 400 and 800
billion dollars yeah billion with a b if
you didn't hear that i said billion
that's a lot of zeros the problem is
that this model makes it possible to
operate basic companies but not to
develop overly complex businesses and
that is exactly one of russia's biggest
problems
the country that has been unable to be
anything more than a mere exporter of
natural resources and then corruption
stifles any possible evolution this is
what explains why russia is one of the
most unequal and least prosperous
countries of course the incentive for
the great russian oligarch is to show
unwavering support to the kremlin to
live the high life and become
ambassadors of moscow in the richest
places in the world of course right now
the sanctions are hitting them hard
[Music]
you see hitting the big oligarchs is
tantamount to hitting the russian state
that is why the allies have targeted
them they are also hoping that
sufficient pressure might even provoke a
shuffling of chairs in moscow after all
it is expected that no one will want to
lose their status all of this explains
why many countries are sanctioning the
oligarchs even more vigorously than
other russian institutions check it out
[Music]
at the moment and as we told you in a
past patreon bulletin russian oligarchs
are seeking refuge in places like dubai
when it comes down to it they are
perhaps the ones who trust putin the
least and by the way if you want to
receive our bulletin the weekly snapshot
just sign up to our patreon community
with your help we can make this project
grow even more and create more and
better independent content in addition
to the weekly snapshot there are options
for receiving a latin politic exclusive
content and unique merchandising we'll
leave you the link in the description
but now it's your turn do you think
sanctions will lead the oligarchs to
betray putin what do you think of this
sort of clique mercantilism that rules
russia should western governments
relentlessly pursue russian oligarchs
leave us your impressions below and now
if you found this video interesting
don't forget to like and subscribe to
visualpolitik all the best and i'll see
you next time
[Music]
you